M
M entschuldigung adventskekse ich esse
die solange es noch geht denn es ist mal
wieder eine Zuckersteuer im Gespräch
dann werden Süßigkeiten und limau teurer
so lässt sich unser Zuckerkonsum um
mehrere Gramm pro Tag Senken der
Bodymaßindex von Kinder nimmt mit jedem
süßgetränk pro Tag um
0,07 Einheiten zu Diabetes ist
mittlerweile der beliebteste Vorname für
Mädchen
aber bevor es soweit ist bringe ich noch
schnell meinen eigenen gezuckerten
Eistee auf den Markt HTI
Geschmacksrichtung Kaktusfeige Zucker
Zimt Zucker flüssige Karies hö beim
Trinken wie dein Herz leise
weint Diabetes noch vor Weihnachten
dafür stehe ich mit meinem guten Namen
los Kauf den Scheiß